>>> BACK TO CAPITOL HILL, HERE
IS ANOTHER LOOK AT THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WHO STAGED A MASS
FREE WALK TO THE SENATE, TODAY,
WHERE MASKS ARE NOT REQUIRED.
THEY ARE AGAINST THE NEW MASK
RULE FOR THE HOUSE PUT IN PLACE
BY THE CHAMBER'S ATTENDING
PHYSICIAN, A DOCTOR.
YESTERDAY, ON THE FIRST DAY OF
THE MASK REQUIREMENT FOR THE
HOUSE, AT LEAST 24 REPUBLICANS
WERE SEEN DEFYING IT, INCLUDING
CONGRESSWOMAN LAUREN BOEBERT.
THAT SAME DAY, A WITNESS TOLD
CNN THAT BOEBERT THREW A MASK
BACK AT A HOUSE STAFFER, WHEN
SHE WAS OFFERED ONE.
BOEBERT'S OFFICE SAID SHE SIMPLY
SLID THE MASK ACROSS A TABLE.
BACK IN HER DISTRICT, IN WESTERN
COLORADO, IN SOUTHERN PARTS OF
THE STATE ACCORDING TO THE CDC,
WITH A HIGH CASE COUNT.
THE NORTH WEST CORNER OF THE
STATE, WHERE THE VACCINATION
RATE IS LOW, AND THE CASES HIGH.
HERE IS GARY'S REPORT.
>> Reporter: CONGRESSWOMAN
LAUREN BOEBERT IS A FLAMETHROWER
ON TWITTER SAYING THINGS LIKE
COVID-19 MUTATED INTO COMMUNISM
A LONG TIME AGO.
AND THE EASIEST WAY TO MAKE THE
DELTA VARIANT GO AWAY AND TO
TURN OFF CNN AND VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
A TWEET, SHE LATER DELETED AND
AT A SPEECH AT CPAC, WHERE SHE
IMPLIED THAT FEDERAL WORKERS
WOULD BRING VACCINES TO PEOPLE'S
HOMES.
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT BEING
DONE.
>> DON'T COME KNOCKING ON MY
DOOR WITH YOUR FAUCI OUCHIE.
YOU LEAVE US THE HELL ALONE.
>> Reporter: AND THEN, THERE WAS
THIS TWEET.
TROTTING OUT HITLER AND HIS
THIRD REICH, BIDEN HAS DEPLOYED
NEEDLE NAZIS TO MESA COUNTY,
WHICH IS ONE OF THE COUNTIES IN
OUR DISTRICT.
WHAT WAS SHE THINKING WITH THAT
TWEET AND THE OTHER THINGS SHE'S
WRITTEN AND SAID?
WE WENT TO CAPITOL HILL TO ASK
HER.
>> REPRESENTATIVE BOEBERT,
QUESTION FOR YOU.
WHY DID YOU USE THE TERM NEEDLE
NAZIS ON YOUR TWITTER FEED?
WERE YOU TRYING TO MAKE FUN OF
PEOPLE?
LIKEN THEM TO HITLER?
ANY COMMENT AT ALL?
THE TRAGIC FACT IS MUCH OF
LAUREN BOEBERT'S CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT IS NOW A COVID-HOT
ZONE, AMID THIS DELTA-VARIANT
SURGE.
HERE IN MOSTLY RURAL THIRD
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT,
TRANSMISSION RATES ARE
DANGEROUSLY HIGH IN MOST OF THE
DISTRICT'S COUNTIES.
VACCINATION RATES, LOW.
>> IT'S AS BAD AS WE HAVE SEEN
SINCE THE BEGINNING.
>> Reporter: MEMORIAL REGIONAL
HOSPITAL HAD TO RE-OPEN ITS
COVID UNIT, WHERE PEOPLE ARE
GETTING SICK AND DYING.
ANDY DANIELS, WHO DESCRIBES
HIMSELF AS A SUPERCONSERVATIVE
INDIVIDUAL, IS THE HOSPITAL'S
CHIEF-EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
HOW DOES IT MAKE YOU FEEL, THE
WAY REPRESENTATIVE BOEBERT HAS
TREATED THIS PANDEMIC?
THE MASKS?
THE VACCINE?
>> YOU KNOW, I AM EMBARRASSED
FOR COLORADO, QUITE FRANKLY.
I AM EMBARRASSED THAT SHE IS MY
REPRESENTATIVE.
UM, I --
>> SO, YOU ARE THE CEO OF AN
IMPORTANT HOSPITAL IN HER
DISTRICT, AND YOU ARE WILLING TO
GO OUT ON A LIMB AND SAY THAT?
>> I AM.
I THINK IF YOU ARE GOING TO TAKE
A STANCE IN HEALTHCARE POLICY,
YOU MIGHT ACTUALLY WANT TO LEARN
SOMETHING ABOUT HEALTHCARE
POLICY.
>> Reporter: THIS DOCTOR IS THE
HOSPITAL'S EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER.
>> I THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE
LISTENING TO WHAT SHE IS SAYING,
AND A LOT OF WHAT SHE IS PUTTING
OUT THERE IS IDEOLOGY THAT ISN'T
FACT, ISN'T MEDICALLY SOUND.
AND IT'S PUTTING A LOT OF PEOPLE
AT DANGER AND IT'S, QUITE
HONESTLY, COSTING PEOPLE LIVES
AND IT'S FRUSTRATING TO HAVE TO
FIGHT AGAINST THAT.
>> Reporter: DOCTOR AND CEO
WOULD BOTH LIKE A CHANCE TO
SPEAK TO LAUREN BOEBERT ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND SHOW HER THINGS, LIKE THIS.
78-YEAR-OLD ROBERT EDWARDS IS A
PATIENT IN THE COVID UNIT.
THE HUSBAND, FATHER,
GRANDFATHER, AND GREAT
GRANDFATHER, WHO ALREADY HAD
COMORBIDITIES WAS QUITE SICK
WHEN HE CAME IN.
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
>> I FEEL A LOT BETTER.
>> ROBERT HAS IMPROVED VERY
SIGNIFICANTLY.
DOCTORS BELIEVE THE REASON FOR
THAT IS BECAUSE HE DID RECEIVE
THE COVID VACCINE.
>> YOU THINK YOU COULD HAVE DIED
IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE THE VACCINE?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT.
>> Reporter: A FEW HOURS AFTER I
SAT DOWN WITH HIM, ROBERT WAS
RELEASED FROM THE HOSPITAL.
I KNOW THOSE ARE TEARS OF
HAPPINESS.
>> CORRECT.
IT WAS SCARY.
>> I KNOW.
>> Reporter: HOSPITAL OFFICIALS
SAY, REPRESENTATIVE BOEBERT HAS
NOT PAID A VISIT TO THIS
HOSPITAL TO SEE PEOPLE, LIKE
ROBERT, SINCE SHE WAS ELECTED TO
CONGRESS LAST NOVEMBER.
SHE, ALSO, WOULD NOT RESPOND TO
ME, WHEN I TRIED TO TALK TO HER
ONE MORE TIME, AS SHE WAS
LEAVING THE CAPITOL.
>> REPRESENTATIVE BOEBERT, I
JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU ONE CHANCE
TO ANSWER A QUESTION, IF YOU
WANT TO.
IT'S VERY UNUSUAL, ANDERSON, FOR
HOSPITAL OFFICIALS TO TALK
NEGATIVELY ABOUT AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL.
AND THESE TWO MEN TOOK NO JOY IN
TALKING TO ME ABOUT THAT.
BUT WHEN YOU ARE A DOCTOR OR A
NURSE OR A CEO OF A HOSPITAL,
YOUR MAIN PRIORITY IS KEEPING
PEOPLE HEALTHY.
AND KEEPING PEOPLE ALIVE AND
THEY ARE GRAVELY CONCERNED THAT
PEOPLE ARE CONTINUING TO BE
UNHEALTHY HERE, AND CONTINUING
TO DIE IN THIS SMALL COUNTY.
AND THEY BELIEVE, ANDERSON, THAT
IF REPRESENTATIVE BOEBERT SPOKE
HONESTLY AND HONORABLY ABOUT
THIS PANDEMIC, HER WORDS AND HER
ACTIONS COULD BE VERY
INFLUENTIAL AND COUL